yesterday as donald trump was sending
tweet
after deranged tweet from the white
house possibly hopped up on the mania
caused by this steroid
dexamethasone that he's on to treat
coronavirus
joe biden went to gettysburg
pennsylvania and delivered
one of the best political speeches i've
seen in years at minimum now for years
most of the speeches have been for
for by trump so that this bar was not
necessarily high
it it's really hard to care about
political speeches
when you follow this stuff so closely
the way that i do
because rarely is any one speech
particularly good or notable but joe
biden's speech yesterday in gettysburg
was fantastic and most importantly
it was the right speech at the right
time so let's look at some clips here is
joe biden talking about the division
in the country take a look there's no
more fitting place
than here today in gettysburg
to talk about the cost of division
about how much it has cost america in
the past
about how much it is costing us now
and about why i believe in this moment
we must come together as a nation
i have to say this was a well-written
speech
but it also fits as such a perfect
contrast to trump's antics trump's
antics are making it so easy
to write these and to simply be the
adult
in the room in comparison to the mess
that's going on
it was a well done speech regardless but
donald trump is really helping joe biden
here joe biden going on later in this
discussion to talk about the racial
unrest and again
this is so politically smart because
when you look at the top three
issues for voters coronavirus the
economy
in light of coronavirus and racial
unrest in this country and and law
enforcement
trumps underwater on all three trump's
approval is in the toilet on all three
and for joe biden to focus on this is
very politically astute
in recent weeks and months the country
has been riled by
instances of excessive police force
heart-wrenching cases of racial
injustice and lives needlessly and
senselessly lost
by peaceful protesters giving voice to
the calls for justice
by examples of violence and looting and
burning that cannot be
tolerated i believe in law and order
i've never supported the funding the
police but i also believe
injustice is real that's a product of a
history
that goes back 400 years the moment when
black
men women and children first were
brought here in chains
i do not believe we have to choose
between law and order
and racial justice in america joe biden
is simply making
a contrast that actually makes itself
joe biden seems competent joe biden
seems stable
he seems like a steady hand period that
is the contrast
and it was so evident in this speech joe
biden going on to talk about
masks you know trump rip it removing his
mask when he arrived back at the white
house
uh in an evita-like moment that some are
calling covida
which is just great joe biden explaining
masks are not political they're
scientific
vaccines are not political they are
scientific and the big focus on trump's
coronavirus failures
makes perfect sense given the polling
it's estimated
that nearly another 210 000 americans
could lose their lives by the end of the
year
enough no more
let's just set partisanship aside let's
end the politics and follow the science
wearing a mask wearing a mask is not a
political
statement it's a scientific
recommendation
social distancing isn't a political
statement
it's a scientific recommendation
testing tracing the development
and all the approval and distribution of
a vaccine isn't a political statement
it is a science-based decision
we can undo what has been done we can't
go back we can do
so much better and you know although it
hasn't been in the news as much
because of captain covid catching the
virus
we again had nearly 45 000 cases
yesterday
it's building again and it could be
getting much worse as we get
to election day over the next 27 days
joe biden
starting to wind down the speech with a
conciliatory message
that is very much welcome to millions of
americans are welcomed by
millions of americans as president
i will embrace hope not fear peace
not violence generosity not
greed and light not darkness
i'll be a president who appeals to the
best in us not the worst
i'll be a president who pushes toward
the future
not one who clings to the past i'm ready
to fight for you and for our nation
every day without exception without
reservation
and with a full and devoted heart
we cannot and will not allow extremists
and white supremacists
to overturn the america of lincoln and
harriet tubman
and frederick douglass and then biden
clarifying
and again this is not it was a very
well-written speech
the concept of a conciliatory message
is not that notable but because the
contrast
is trump joe biden clarifying he will be
the president for everyone
is again a really great way to draw
contrast
he's used to work joe but they can't
work that way anymore
well i'm here to tell you they can and
they must
if we're going to get anything done
i'm running as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work with democrats and republicans
i work as hard for those who don't
support me
as those who do that's the job of a
president
the duty to care for everyone
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
is not due to some mysterious force
beyond our control
it's a decision it's a choice we make
and if we can decide not to cooperate we
can decide
to cooperate as well just pitch perfect
pitch perfect this is the message
america wants and needs to hear right
now
we have to go in a different direction
what we've been doing isn't working
it's a complete speech it had you know
going
it's like uh middle school english right
it had
a beginning a middle and an end it had a
logical conclusion that followed from
the premises
it was a clear contrast with a sort of
historic
element to it uh biden expressing a
commitment to reuniting a nation that
has been
so divided rightly so this is not one of
those divisions that is artificial
half the country seems unwilling or
unable to realize that we have a
president who has
brought the country to the brink quite
literally
and joe biden very much triggering
donald trump with this speech
shortly after biden was done uh in
pennsylvania remember
the speech was in gettysburg
pennsylvania donald trump tweeted
how does biden lead in pennsylvania
polls when he is against
fracking jobs second amendment and
religion of course those are all lies
fake polls trump says i will win
pennsylvania hopefully not we're going
to talk about arizona later
but in the latest polls out of
pennsylvania biden leading by an
average of 6.3 and by as much as
11 in the latest monmouth poll biden can
win pennsylvania
early voting is happening now in
pennsylvania it started weeks ago
and runs through october 27th we have
the opportunity
let's make it happen if you were voting
already in pennsylvania or wherever
let me know how it's going i'm on
twitter at d pacman
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech
scientists with only one mission which
is to help people
quit smoking and vaping by offering a
clean
affordable nicotine alternative now
many of you know you've heard the
stories i've known several people in my
life who have struggled with quitting
smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video
and you'll get 20 off when you use the
coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical